- [Man] From the same guy.
Full zip Macho Man.
- [Gary] Holy shit!
I'm fucking wearing
this shit all the time.
Ooh, yeah.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Jordan] Hold.
Good.
- [Gary] Saturday.
Not a whole lot of
DailyVee action.
The weekends are always
going to be a little tricky.
Jordan and I pumping
out a quick
15, 20 minute workout.
Happy birthday, Max.
Went to the birthday
party, went to Jers.
That was fun.
Just been reading
all the comments,
engaging, very
hip hop kind of week.
That's why we do this, man.
I've been looking forward to it.
- [Saba] Yeah.
- If I could do what
you did, I'd be the fuck,
I'd be real fucking famous
because I really
understand distribution.
My whole thing--
- [Yung] You gotta take a shot.
- Done.
My dad's gonna be real happy.
(hip hop music)
- Good is the evil of great.
- If Drake put up 365 days of
songs the rest of his life,
he would win.
- [ASAP] How you doin', buddy?
- Such a pleasure my man.
How are you?
- I'm good.
- Smell good, man.
- [ASAP] I appreciate it.
- Which was fun.
Just grinding.
Just a lot going on.
Such an interesting thing.
When I was filming
"Planet of the Apps"
a couple weeks ago,
or in December, Will.i.am was
trying to razz me and get this
kid to go on his team 'cause
"Planet of the Apps" is a
little more like "The Voice",
it's the "Shark Tank" meets
"The Voice" for apps.
So we're trying to get people to
go on our team so we can mentor
them to get in front of the VC
and so he's trying to get this
one app to,
God, my arms are tired.
Hold this Jordan,
just hold it like this.
So he's trying to get this one
app kid to go with him and he
goes, "Look," and we were
talking about marketing and
getting people to
download the app.
He goes, "Look, if you want to
you want to go with marketing,
"if the marketing's what
going to kill it for your app,
"then you gotta go with GaryVee.
"He's the best
marketer I've ever seen,
"best marketer in the world.
"But if you care about culture,
then you've got,"
and I was so fucking pissed.
I'm like, "Mother fucking,
Will.i.am," it was a great move.
I jumped in, I'm like, "Look, if
you like culture and marketing
"so much Will,
why are headphone companies
"working with my
company, VaynerMedia?"
So we were razzing but what's
been interesting over the last
two to four weeks,
looking at meme culture,
looking at
Instagram influencers,
looking at Facebook video,
looking at hip hop emerging
talent, you know Flippa and
Swag Hollywood
and Saba, some
of the kids I'm
hanging out with.
Just really looking at
the business landscape.
Why commercials aren't working,
there's this incredible
moment right now.
I feel like I'm penetrating
this like culture force field
and I can see it.
All the pieces coming together
and the way that Will calls it
culture, I call it attention,
day trading attention,
attention arbitrage.
These subcultures,
Jordan, fitness influencers,
hip hop influencers,
cartoon influencers,
gamers on Twitch, you know,
the entrepreneur hackers.
You know, this interesting
convoluted matrix that
is moving every day.
Musical.ly, Snapchat,
Instagram, you know,
Facebook doing much more
20 to 30 than people think
(clicks tongue).
You know, stuff like
that, really fascinating.
I feel like I'm in it.
I feel like I'm really in it.
I'm in it right now.
Spring, summer
the show comes out.
Just feel like
2017's gonna be a beast.
What up everybody?
Real quick we're gonna start
using clips from a year ago.
Things that we filmed in
DailyVee that happened a year
ago as contact points or make
fun of my predictions that were
wrong or just DailyVee classics
that add a little spice,
especially the weekend episodes.
So, hope you check it.
(tape loading)
You're just hacking DailyVee.
- Yeah. You gotta put my
handle in this time,
Dan Grossman.
Although, I think,
yeah, your followers,
anyway, I shouldn't
have this on record.
- What?
My followers are amazing.
This is entrepreneurship.
- You can't fake the musician,
you can fake the attitude.
- In entrepreneurship,
everybody in America,
everybody
watching this right now,
it's the American
thing to believe,
people don't think of
entrepreneurship as a skill.
- [Dan] Right.
- They don't think
they can be LeBron or be,
you know, Nine Inch Nails,
or be 50 Cent.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- But everybody looks at
me and says I can do that.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- They don't
understand that it's a talent.
By the way--
- [Dan] Yeah?
- The other thing that's,
it's more practical to actually
recognize I'm a talent and let's
say they think I'm a hunter,
I'm the best.
- Yeah.
- Them being a 68 is actually
quite financially and
happiness worthy,
whereas you look
at LeBron and he's 100,
being a 68 means that, like,
you'll spend a lot of time in
rec leagues, like,
like, there's a different,
right--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It costs you money--
- Mhmmm.
- to try to be a 68 musician.
You paid 15,000 demo.
You have overhead,
like, you can't pay rent.
- [Dan] Yeah, yeah.
- This thing, being a 60, even
for the people that are clearly,
understand that they're
not me, talentwise...
- [Dan] Yeah.
- It's actually quite
practical to be a 68.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)